[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing albus
dumbledore and the curse with which he
was afflicted
albus dumbledore was the most powerful
wizard of his era and the sudden tragic
news of his death sent shockwaves
throughout britain but while many
mourned others rejoiced with dumbledore
out of the picture
voldemort and his death eaters had
removed the single largest obstacle in
their rise to power and even though
severus snape might have cast the final
spell that killed the much beloved
headmaster of hogwarts it was lord
voldemort's curse that truly murdered
him
so you might be curious what exactly did
voldemort do to marvolo gaunt's ring in
order to have such a lethal effect
we'll uncover that mystery and more in
today's video marvolo gaunt's ring as
we've already mentioned there was much
more to dumbledore's death than the
final curse that severus snape cast
during the battle of the astronomy tower
months before that conflict albus
dumbledore had tracked down one of
voldemort's horcruxes a small ring
crowned with a strange dark stone
the ring wasn't just another personal
item of tom riddles like the diary that
harry destroyed in the chamber of
secrets no this ring actually contained
one of the deathly hallows the dark
stone that rested within was none other
than the resurrection stone an ancient
magical relic that had the power to
summon spirits back from the dead when
voldemort had stolen the ring from his
uncle morphin gaunt he presumed it was
just an heirloom passed from generation
to generation within the gaunt household
and even though voldemort was
technically part of the gaunt family he
had been born out of wedlock and to a
muggle father no less his theft of the
ring despite whatever complex emotions
urged him wasn't motivated by a desire
for the resurrection stone
but even if voldemort knew that the ring
contained such a powerful hallow he
might not have changed his decision
because in the end it was the allure of
the resurrection stone that prompted
dumbledore to slide the ring onto his
finger and receive voldemort's lethal
curse
when alba saw the distinct markings on
the stone he realized that it was one of
the three deathly hallows and although
possessing the elder wand might have
been nice dumbledore would have traded
all that power for one last chance to
see his sister ariana again and in that
brief moment when his eyes first met the
stone albus completely forgot the dark
charms with which voldemort had cursed
his horcruxes
effects on dumbledore in the end the
price for dumbledore's momentary lapse
in judgment was death voldemort had
placed a complex curse on marvel gaunt's
ring one that would kill any wizard who
dare try us on
had dumbledore been a lesser wizard the
curse would have stopped his heart on
the spot
but with the help of severus snape the
curse was confined to a single hand
granting the headmaster a year or so to
live until death would finally take him
when you look at the immediate aftermath
of the curse you might have thought it
was a slow acting killing charm
many readers have misunderstood the
effects of the curse and believe that it
took far longer to murder its victims
than it actually did
but as we've already explained albus
situation was unique and it took every
ounce of professor snape's experience to
halt the progression of the curse
and even that would only last for a few
months
how exactly was the spell made
by now you might be wondering how
exactly did voldemort create such a
horrifying curse
well the answer to that question is
pretty complex
although jk rowling has given us
hundreds of spells and charms and a long
list of spellcrafters to go along with
them she never actually explains how
they're created in fact spellcraft is
one of the most mysterious parts of
harry potter law
if we compare it to another magical
discipline like concocting potions
making spells is the most advanced
discipline that a wizard can aspire to
with a simple search through one of the
books on professor slughorn's wall you
can find a full list of ingredients and
a step-by-step procedure for any number
of potions but spellcraft was different
the dangers of new spells
actually one of the only things we know
about creating new spells is just how
dangerous it was
all we have to do is look at the tale of
poor luna lovegood's mother pandora
lovegood to see how true this was
while luna was still a young girl
pandora tried her hand at creating a new
spell
we'll never know what luna's mother was
trying to achieve with the new charm as
no written records of the spell's
origins survived but at some point while
trying to bring her magical goal to life
the spell backfired
in a horrible storm of magic pandora's
body was mutilated and she died on the
spot
leaving luna motherless in the process
what we do know although jk rowling
hasn't written much about the creation
of spells and curses we can make a few
general assumptions based on harry
potter's classes at hogwarts throughout
the years in general beginner students
needed three or four basic components to
effectively pull off a spell
drawing a pattern with their wand
reciting and incantation
their own innate magical abilities and
perhaps
other body movements like whipping the
wand with their arm at the final moment
but these requirements were strictly for
beginners
the more powerful the wizard the fewer
external tools they required albus
dumbledore and lord voldemort in
particular were highly skilled at
non-verbal and wonderless magic
with only his incredible skill and
magical abilities voldemort likely was
able to create the curse on my volagan's
ring without harming himself unlike
other witches and wizards like pandora
lovegood
although curses were capable of lying
dormant in physical objects and
attacking their victims upon physical
contact it's interesting to note that
voldemort didn't seem to use a version
of the killing curse on the ring
instead he opted for a different custom
curse that ultimately resulted in murder
what did other unique curses look like
to be honest voldemort's method for
creating the curse on mavoligan's ring
might be a little too esoteric to be
satisfying unlike the swelling solution
which was a potion with straightforward
ingredients like dried nettles and
puffer fish eyes voldemort's dark magic
probably involved a lot more intangibles
but at least we can look at other custom
cursors that arose during the 20th
century to see what cursecraft could
create
at one point in the 90s a dark wizard
placed a curse on a cd case if you so
much as placed a single finger on the
square plastic container you would burst
out in a fit of laughter
but it wasn't simply a pleasant chuckle
the laughing would continue forever
another cursed relic an opal necklace
from borgen and burke came to notoriety
in the 90s as well
the curse placed upon it caused its
victim to levitate into the air and die
in horrific fashion
even those that didn't wear the necklace
and merely touched it with their bare
skin could be killed
voldemort himself was responsible for
countless curses throughout the century
it was reported that he had cast a curse
upon the office of defense against the
dark arts at hogwarts
so long as voldemort lived whoever
taught the subject at hogwarts was
destined to die or lose his place after
only a year of work
how could the curse be broken now if you
ever became the victim of curse the
first thought on your mind might be how
do i cure it thankfully plenty of curses
have easy to find remedies and even the
most extreme curses could be undone if
the creator was killed but in
dumbledore's case the curse upon marvel
gaunt's ring was particularly vile
even after severus snape spent weeks
studying it the wizards failed to find a
cure
the best they could hope to do was slow
the curse's spread
however since the curse was designed to
protect one of voldemort's horcruxes
dumbledore was able to get some good
from the situation
using the sword of godric gryffindor
which was armed with the venom of the
chamber of secrets basilisk the
headmaster hacked at the ring destroying
the horcrux in the process
conclusion
when we look back at the curse of
marvolo gaunt's ring for a final time
we'll find all the familiar cruelty that
made voldemort such a successful dark
wizard the curse had a simple purpose it
was designed to take the life of whoever
wore its anchor
and the anchor itself wasn't just a
valuable treasure trove or a sacred text
it was a horcrux an act of dark magic
that was even too vile for some of the
most famous dark wizards in history
but in the end voldemort's magic proved
to be too strong for even the combined
strength of dumbledore and snape to
overcome
with his death looming on the horizon
dumbledore decided to find some use for
his death and ask snape to kill him and
draw himself closer to voldemort and
that's it for this video what do you
guys think could dumbledore have
survived if he had held on until
voldemort was dead do you know what this
curse is
leave a comment down below
if you enjoy the videos please show your
support by hitting the like button and
subscribing to the channel
until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live